[Music]
welcome back to the cbs this morning
saturday we begin this half hour with a
report on the big gap in who gets the
coronavirus vaccine in the u.s
information from 23 states that report
coveted vaccinations by race and
ethnicity
shows a stark difference in the rollout
with communities hit hardest by the
virus
lagging or left behind here's adriana
diaz
blacks and latinos are more likely to
die from covid but less likely to be
vaccinated
early vaccination data shows that black
americans lag significantly behind white
americans
take maryland where 63 percent of doses
have gone to whites
and 15 percent to blacks though they
make up 31 percent of the population
in texas partial data shows that 9 of
vaccine recipients are hispanic
the hispanics are nearly 40 percent of
the state's population
i do not feel that we in southeast
austin have the same access to the
vaccine
a disparity austin city councilwoman
vanessa fuentes sees in her mostly
latino district
we don't have the traditional
infrastructure
of hospitals and pharmacies in addition
to less access
vaccine hesitancy is another barrier
even in health care settings
where 37 percent of workers either want
to wait and see
or definitely not get the vaccine and
black americans are most hesitant
rhonda jones is a registered nurse what
are your thoughts on the vaccine
i say no it came out just a little bit
too fast for me
she works at chicago's new roseland
community hospital where
73 percent of staff have declined to the
vaccine so
far despite the hospital's outreach
efforts some people might be surprised
to learn that you
someone in the medical field don't want
to take the vaccine right now
well i would say that's just me being a
good nurse you have to learn a little
bit about it before you do it
she wants to wait and see for cbs this
morning saturday
adriana diaz chicago
i think of your piece that you did with
the woman who created this scene
and everybody has their own belief but
again
they've done the test they this is
something that is good yeah
and everyone you know i was like it's
been pretty well studied yeah well i'm
thinking everyone has a right to do what
they
want to do sort of but this is a medical
epidemic public health crisis and it
really is important